while a great many people see you as
heroes there are some would prefer the
word vigilantes
what I love about vision he's sort of on
his own quest which is to understand
human beings and he realizes that
loyalty has got to come through love
real loyalty so I think that he's very
intrigued by what love is friends I know
you believe what you're doing is right
but for the collective good I cannot
allow this to continue he's trying to
get both sides to behave in a manner
that's acceptable and move forward in a
very logical way it's complicated by the
fact that he is starting to experience
affection for scrummage spirits lifted
which is something from the books that's
a great great arc for him the way that
they've intelligently linked them is
that they're powered from the same
source
so wherever she gets her powers actually
came from the same stone that gives him
his whole life miss maximov manipulates
molecular polarity allowing her to alter
reality I I'm a little harder to explain
hey youtubers it's Charlie so new
Scarlet Witch envision teaser haven't
really talked about them in a while but
let's break it down there's some
comic-book stuff that they'll follow up
they'll continue to follow up on an
infinity war so a lot of you know at
least a little bit about their history
in the comics they were basically
together there were a couple for a long
time
they even had children together which
was really freaky considering the vision
is an AI but then later comics had
really fun with that and turn it into
this big Mephisto plot in drove Scarlet
Witch and saying it turned to this big
no more mutant storyline so it became
this big thing so there was this really
campy relationship that later more
hardcore comics put a really gritty spin
on so like the Russo said during civil
war they just kind of winked at that a
little bit their power comes from the
same source in the MCU which isn't true
in the comics but you can understand how
they're linking them in the movies so
that it becomes a much bigger thing in
infinity war as they both try to
understand who they are how their powers
work and what their relationship is
going to be because Thanos form in the
Infinity Gauntlet is going to need the
mind gem so he's gonna have to rip it
right out of vision skull so maybe
that's gonna be like the no more mutants
type storyline for Scarlet Witch
infinity or where she just loses it
because she'll still have her powers
when Thanos takes the mind gem you know
vision is the only one that we're
worried about at the end of Civil War
she was kind of on the down-and-out it's
like she almost died during that big
battle so it almost seems like they're
gonna be flipping that for infinity war
and she'll be the one to take care of
him even though she's kind of like on
CAPS Secret Avengers now she's still
wanted by the law but you can see how
like she envisioned even though they had
some tension he was forced to put him
down so to speak when she escaped with
Hawkeye they don't hate each other like
old married couples they tend to fight a
lot Captain America Iron Man best
example of that they almost killed each
other they took it way further past the
line and still later at the end they
were able to acknowledge that moment
with Iron Man where he was kind of
moving past it slowly like even before
their big final fight he acknowledges
that he understands what Steve is doing
even though he doesn't care he's like I
don't care he killed my mother so he
completely understands where Steve is
coming from it's the same thing with
Scarlet Witch envisioned they will come
back to the point in infinity war and I
wouldn't be surprised like vision has
this connect
to electronics because he's AI he
probably wouldn't have too hard of a
time tracking Scarlet Witch down if he
really wanted to like the way they keep
track of hoax movements on earth before
the first Avengers film like banners
hiding out in the jungle they know where
he is they're just leaving him beat like
Nick Fury's like we're just gonna leave
him alone until they need him so based
on the changes they've made in the MCU
let me know what you think is going to
happen with Scarlet Witch envision when
Thanos takes the mind gem do you think
it's going to kill vision in Drive
Scarlet Witch crazy in the way that that
happened with her children during the
comics now because of all the x-men IP
issues they don't have mutants in the
MCU so she can't do the no more mutants
thing but she can't just go off the
charts they almost had like a brief
moment of that during age of Ultron so
there might be like an even bigger
version of that because they did say
between age of Ultron in Civil War her
powers had grown so I would expect that
they continued to evolve and in the clip
to vision even says it's like a
behind-the-scenes moment but he says
Scarlet Witch has the ability to change
reality which actually is true to the
comics they just don't get into the
Chaos magic from Scarlet Witch in the
comics which gets into mythos no stuff
but I've talked a little bit about that
during my Doctor Strange videos Dormammu
is probably going to be the MCU stand-in
for Mephisto because they're both really
evil characters they kind of worked the
same way Dormammu is just more powerful
Mephisto is just like a more common
villain I would almost think of him as
more low level but technically they're
both incredibly powerful so I don't
think they're gonna bother to
distinguish between those two things in
the movies in Dormammu is like so far
off in the movies anyway that I think
it's going to be a long time before they
ever get to that but I am curious to see
what happens with Scarlet Witch in phase
4 I think they're trying to balance the
Avengers team out and in terms of men
and women like you have Captain Marvel
coming in Captain America is kind of on
the outs you know even though all those
characters still exist I think it's
going to be a lot more fun Avengers team
like the energy will be really fun once
we get the wasp in there she won't debut
till after infinity war though like an
actual wasp costume maybe some hat tips
during infinity war but ant-man in the
wasp is being released after Avengers
infinity war so if you really like
female Avengers there's probably gonna
be a whole lot more and phase 4
hopefully vision
doesn't go away forever either if they
kill off vision during infinity war or
somehow put on ice when Thanos has the
mind gem maybe they'll use that as a way
to bring back Ultron for like a really
brief teaser like don't forget vision is
kind of like Ultron Jarvis in the mind
gems baby so there is Ultron programming
in there they could always reassert
itself if he loses the mind gem but I
think ultimately it would be more
satisfied like a more dramatic moment if
that were just like put him on ice and
make it look like he was dead so that it
becomes this big moment for Scarlet
Witch is character but I don't think
they're literally going to go to
relationship territory like you're not
going to see Scarlet Witch trying to
have sex with a robot that would be
pretty ridiculous you have to remember
that this is a Disney movie even if it's
a pg-13 Disney movie so any physical
relationship that they have at the point
of infinity war will probably only be
implied like implied relationship but
not literal relationship so in related
news I will say congratulations to the
new blu-ray giveaway winner the Civil
War blu-ray giveaway winner
Shuma gorath be sure to private message
me on the back end of my channel
it's basically an Amazon gift card for
the value of the Civil War blu-ray so
the giveaway will just keep going till
the blu-ray actually physically drops
which is in a couple days so new round
starts now
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video I know it's kind of a bummer that
a lot of you had to go back to school
this week but there's still like a whole
bunch of awesome stuff happening giving
away pretty flash stuff this week giving
away free Civil War stuff get hype it's
going to be awesome and here's a teaser
for you James Gunn was answering a bunch
of questions recently he confirmed that
the guardians of the galaxy trailer is
dropping before Christmas so that's
pretty much confirmation that it's going
to drop some time between Doctor Strange
and Star Wars rogue one which is coming
out like two weeks before Christmas so I
think it's going to be attached to rogue
one but they could drop at any time
between those two movies where you guys
wait for that to post you can click here
for that flash giveaway video and you
can click here learn all about shocker
and spider-man homecoming thank you so
much for watching everybody let's at
five I'll see you guys